c'était ma bouche en 2017 c'est moi
aucune idée
absolument irrité
en fait elle fait beaucoup beaucoup de
placement etc sur Instagram aussi ils
sont sur la plupart de ses revenus
viennent de l'influence donc elle est
beaucoup beaucoup sur les réseaux elle
se fait beaucoup critiquer forcément la
3 millions de d'abonnés et notamment sur
son physique parce que certains disent
que ça bouge ses yeux ont changé qu'elle
fait de la chirurgie esthétique
elle a dit non non regardez les photos
en 2017 c'était ma bouche etc et elle en
profite aussi pour vanter les crèmes et
certains produits qu'elle utilisent et
qui lui peut-être qui était super drôle
c'est que quand on était énergie 12
Stéphane George que j'embrasse qui était
le patron un jour convoque Benoît et lui
dit c'est hyper drôle pourquoi alors que
Benoît avait déjà fait
il avait déjà fait le sexe les joues il
avait fait tout sauf une partie et lui
dit et lui dit ah oui s'il te plaît ne
fais pas la bouche c'est trop voyant il
a jamais fait la bouche voilà c'était il
m'a dit de faire gonfler l'élève c'est
horrible à l'antenne
c'est la seule chose qui est naturel
chez moi
super drôle donc voilà au lieu de tomber
dessus soit pas beaucoup de bon faut
dire comme ça